the green versus blue text bubble debate
is about a lot more than just a color
that's a red flag about someone right
they text you green text bubble pop
saying what the
Android people are divided but there's
another rivalry happening here too
between Google and apple here's what you
need to know in three minutes
when you text someone from a different
operating system you may have noticed
that some features don't work as well
photos and videos show up blurry and you
don't get read receipts and the three
dots showing you that someone's writing
back those don't show up either that's
because your phone is sending them an
SMS or a basic text message but now
Google wants Apple to switch to RCS a
new messaging standard RCS or Rich
communication Services is the Modern
Standard adopted by most of the mobile
world Google says it would make the
experience more inclusive for everyone
but would it really or would it just
make more people open to switching from
Apple roughly 40 percent of U.S
consumers use iPhones but for those ages
18 to 24 that number jumps to more than
70 percent
Google says RCS can do everything
iMessage can do like encryption and
sending high quality images RCS was
designed to be an open standard meaning
it could allow features to work more
seamlessly between different types of
phones this video wasn't easy to make
Google is running social media ads
hoping that Apple will get the message
all that sounds nice but Google stands
to benefit too Google says when bran
sends you an interactive text like this
compared to a simple text like this
customers are 74 more likely to engage
so businesses trying to sell you merch
or Services through text might be more
inclined to sign up Google doesn't just
support the protocol but it helps create
the version that it's pushing with all
the bells and whistles analysts tell me
Google might also want widespread RCS so
that it can serve up other offerings
like Google pay and Google Maps inside
more people's messaging apps but Apple
doesn't seem to be motivated by Google's
campaign and doesn't actually need RCS
Apple's messaging app already has all
the modern texting features and can be
used across multiple devices
and iMessage is so popular it helps
Apple retain iPhone users by locking
them into the company's ecosystem Apple
employees have admitted that iMessage
makes it hard to leave the company's
universe and expanding those features
Beyond Apple would hurt the company and
that strategy appears to be working in
the US just look at how many more iPhone
users there are year over year between
the ages of 18 and 24. will RCS emerge
as the new standard the way SMS did
analysts say that's unlikely especially
without apple and they say apple doesn't
have pressing reasons to budge Google
created RCS to be more like iMessage so
why would iMessage have to change I'm
sure we'd all enjoy a universal
messaging standard but it doesn't look
like RCS will be that at least not yet
[Music]